is the thing that makes you a great
writer the same thing that's Stopping
You publishing for many writers the
answer is yes but not only is it keeping
you from publishing your work it's also
sucking the joy out of the writing
process so today I'm going to show you
how I help these writers publish their
first newsletters using what I believe
to be the best way to Kickstart your
writing practice for easy output so what
is it why is it so powerful and how can
it help you come up with your greatest
ideas that's coming up but first you've
got to understand the thing that's
holding you back from writing in the
first place it's editing now of course
nobody's going to say that writers
should never edit their work editing is
a powerful tool if used properly but to
show you what happens when it goes wrong
let me tell you about one of the worst
teachers that I ever had this was when I
was studying French in Montreal my
teacher would call on students randomly
to speak out in class and he had this
habit of interrupting us mid sentence to
correct our mistakes I'll never forget
the day that a German student in our
class named anel
said instead OFA the teacher completely
shut him down in front of the entire
class no well no this was in Quebec so
it was probably something more likeo
that's when I realized a powerful lesson
about editing mistakes after having
spent 10 years of teaching academic and
professional writing to non-native
English speakers let me be the first to
tell you that what language Learners
need is not error correction it's the
comfort and confidence in using the
language so that they can go on using it
outside of the classroom it's only
through the use of the language that we
actually learn how to recognize and
correct mistakes on our own and if that
sounds obvious with language learning
what I want you to realize is that this
is exactly what we do to ourselves
whenever we write it happens to me you
and even Stephen King early in his
career Stephen King worked at a local
newspaper where his editor John Gould
gave him a piece of advice that he never
forgot write with the door closed
rewrite with the door open this advice
underscores a key difference between
writing and rewriting when you're
writing the only audience is you you're
telling yourself the story that's
writing with the door closed but when
you're rewriting the focus shifts to the
reader you're polishing you're cutting
you're clarifying you're making your
ideas understandable to somebody outside
of your own head that's writing with the
door open and the really important point
is to keep these two processes separate
so the problem is not editing per se the
problem is that writers try to edit at
the same time that they're producing
which is like having an editor
constantly looking over your shoulder
criticizing every word before you've
even finished writing the sentence so
how do you break out of this trap how do
you separate writing from editing so
that you can actually finish something
well the trick is simple you need to
practice
non-editing here's how writing 2,000
words in a 2hour writing session is
difficult but you know what's easy
writing 250 words in 15 minutes that's
like one sentence a minute so set a
timer give yourself 15 minutes or
whatever works for you to just write no
backspacing no second guessing no
lifting your fingers off of the keyboard
but what happens when you get stuck you
can't think of the perfect word or you
don't know what happens next well here's
where you use placeholders write the
first word that comes to your mind and
then just write in Brackets find a
better word and keep going when you
practice this inevitably a voice is
going to creep up into your mind and
convince you that you just need to do a
little bit more research you just need
to go get another cup of tea you just
need to clean your living room you just
need to file your taxes and this is
totally natural so whenever this happens
during one of your timed writing
sessions all you need to do is call ly
gently take out some baby powder dust up
your hand and then slap that in
the mouth whenever the timer is going
it's writing time so do not give into
that voice that's trying to convince you
that there's anything else to do and in
this vein it's also helpful to turn off
distractions now I know of course
everybody knows eliminate distractions
but here's what I do personally I like
to write in the program obsidian which
is like a plain text editor this keeps
me out of my browser I really don't
don't know how people can write in
Google Docs because when the browser is
open you can be pulled in any direction
and even with writing in a PL text
editor I still like to use an app called
opal to block my access to other
distracting websites It basically bricks
your phone and your computer so it makes
it impossible to open any other apps or
visit any other websites during your
dedicated writing time finally and this
is the most important part of
non-editing it's that you make a clear
distinction in your mind between writing
and editing and you save editing for
later I've seen in a lot of writers
daily schedules that they'll have their
morning session dedicated to writing and
then you know a block in the afternoon
after lunch to go over things and clean
it up these are two distinct processes
and it's really important to get them
separated in your mind when you're
writing you're producing when you're
editing you're perfecting now of course
editing is important but I say all this
because more often than not editing just
becomes a form of virtuous
procrastination you think you're doing
something good but it's just a strategy
for avoiding the discomfort of writing
writing without editing causes some
amazing things to happen not only do you
get the ideas out of your head and onto
the page but when they're there on the
page your ideas start to grow and take
on a life of their own speaking of
growth here I am at my high school
graduation what a promising young man
and cheios if you're out there call me
and here I am today teaching at one of
the top universities in South Korea hard
to believe that it's the same person
person but the fact is that I grew up in
the same way that everything grows
including your ideas and whenever you
understand how ideas grow you'll stop
being embarrassed by the ideas that seem
so stupid when they come up during these
free writing sessions writing is
thinking and if you're writing about
anything important then you're thinking
thoughts that have never been thought
before you don't quite know how to put
it because there's not like a ready-made
handle for it you've never said this
stuff before you've never brought it up
into language and so of course it's hard
and of course it sounds stupid but when
you write about your ideas before they'
fully formed you actually give them a
chance to grow and mature it works like
this you've set one of your writing
timers and you start writing about an
idea or belief let's call it X so you
write down this belief and you think
it's pretty solid but as you write you
realize something that you didn't quite
expect maybe X isn't as correct as you
thought or maybe you don't even believe
it anymore so you keep writing and now
you're writing about your uncertainty
wrestling with the confusion and then
something clicks a new idea emerges
let's call it why so now you're writing
about why and you explore it develop it
refine it and by the time you finish
you're satisfied you started writing
about X but now you finished writing
about y That's How ideas grow through
writing they evolve as you work on them
transforming into something more refined
and powerful than where they began like
an acorn to a tree or an awkward
teenager to a writing Professor simple
ideas move through a series of changes
each stage more complex and more refine
than the last anytime I've written
something I'm proud of it's because I
allowed that process to happen and
whenever I've struggled or created
something disappointing it's almost
always because I rushed it or didn't let
the process unfold new ideas always
sound stupid or Half Baked when we first
write about them and that's because they
are it's a thought you've never thought
before but if you can bring yourself to
just spit it out you bring that idea
into the world and you give it the space
and the energy that it needs to develop
so think of the ideas that you write
kind of like single celled organisms as
a writer your job is just to give them
energy and to Foster an environment
where they can grow and interact and
most importantly for you to just stay
out of their way and when you write
without the interference of editing
strange and exciting things start to
happen relationship and ideas that are
richer than what you could have planned
start to emerge it starts to feel like
the words and ideas take on a life of
their own and it makes your job as a
writer much simpler you don't need to be
a genius you just need to show up and
help these ideas get to where they're
going so if you want to help your ideas
grow through writing here are some tips
talk to yourself in your writing now
personally whenever I do this I like to
use the pronoun you instead of I so
instead of saying I believe X to be true
you say you believe X to be true this is
something I picked up from the Diaries
of Krishna mury and I always stuck with
it I feel like that switch allows me to
step outside of myself and observe my
thinking without any attachment to the
ideas whenever a sentence feels wrong
don't stop write about why it feels
wrong how you noticed it feels wrong or
whatever else you're thinking about it
this practice breaks down the barrier
between your real ideas and your good
ideas and it frees up your voice third
don't let Beginnings stop you you can
push through with placeholders like the
thing is or what I'm trying to say is or
what I'm writing about is you can always
revise this later just anything to get
you started is good enough fourth as a
teacher I can confirm that having an
audience really helps you know sometimes
I'll be working on a lesson plan all
night and I get really stressed out
because it's just not coming together
and I show up to class the next day
feeling totally unprepared but whenever
I walk into the seminar room everything
just kind of falls into place and the
class is really fluid and fun so if
you're stuck during a writing session
pretend you're speaking to an audience
and you have only 30 minutes to get your
point across set a timer start anywhere
and just keep going often Midway through
you'll get hit with these waves of like
Clarity and inspiration and you say ah
yeah that's what I was trying to say now
if writing really feels impossible for
you then you can switch to talking years
ago I heard a really good interview on
the Tim Ferris podcast and I looked it
up I tried to find it and I can't find
it so if you know this podcast then
please link it down below the like
button but in this podcast uh Tim Ferris
was interviewing a guy who had a pretty
impressive output I think he was a
scientist but he said that all of his
writing happens through uh voice to text
so he speaks into a microphone and the
computer transcribes it and this was a
while ago I remember he was talking
about how he had subscribed to some
expensive software but these days that
text to speech software is totally free
so you can just set a timer speak out
loud as if somebody's listening to you
and keep talking the point is that you
just keep going now if you've tried all
these steps and it's still not working
then honestly don't force it don't swim
upstream if the current is trying to
take you someplace else step away and
listen to the part of you that's
resisting you can do this by taking a
walk or journaling but that voice in you
that's still you and it might have
something important to say now this
messy iterative process is something
that I call working with words whenever
you're working with words you're not
judging the quality of the idea
you're just trying to keep your stream
of Consciousness flowing one word at a
time kind of like a painter showing up
to their Studio not really sure what
they're going to paint that day but
showing up putting in the time and
energy and just playing with the paint
eventually you start to see patterns
emerge these moments of inspiration
aren't pre-planned things they kind of
strike you in the process and by giving
your words this energy and freedom
you'll start to recognize these patterns
and ideas that will emerge and you'll
end up with something far better better
than you could have imagined at the
start but the problem with working with
words is that it makes a total mess I
could never share this with readers so
what's the point that's where the second
part of this writing technique comes in
do you ever find yourself staring at a
blank page waiting for the perfect idea
to strike you like a bolt of lightning
like a bolt of lightning that's pretty
cliche what would be a better simile
waiting for the perfect idea to strike
like a teachers union like a buling
alley do you ever find yourself staring
at an empty page waiting for the perfect
idea to strike I don't know about you
but I often find myself trapped in this
cycle where I'm either writing
passionately or passively waiting for
inspiration but these two modes writing
and waiting for inspiration what if
there is a way to join them to ensure
that you never have to face a blank page
again this is kimchi it's the national
dish of Korea and it's made of cabbage
green onion chili salt and a bunch of
other ingredients I'm going somewhere
with this trust me but kimchi isn't made
by just tossing these ingredients
together like a salad it's the bubbling
fermenting and breaking down that
creates something greater than the sum
of its parts the longer these materials
interact with each other the richier and
funkier it gets funkier we want Funk and
just as kimchi is not simply a mix of
cabbage chilies and spices writing is
not just the words on the page it's the
fermentation of the ideas that create
something extraordinary the words that
we generate during these timed writing
sessions are only the Raw ingredients
but the real magic happens whenever we
mix these ideas together bringing them
together on the page lets them interact
and ferment and that transforms them
into something richer and deeper and
funkier even if the ideas don't seem to
belong together they can lead to
surprising interactions idea a probably
seemed too basic or simple whenever you
first wrote it but now it becomes a
metaphor for explaining one aspect of
idea B idea C sounded so cliche when you
first wrote it but now it could become a
new lens for understanding idea D so
just as fermentation drives the creation
of kimchi's complex flavors the
interaction of these ideas can lead you
to new insights and that is where I
found the best ideas come from so here
are some simple steps that you can use
in your next writing session in order to
funkify your ideas the easiest way to do
this is to alternate between working
with words and working with IDE is it
doesn't matter which one comes first if
you want to begin by working with words
then it's like we said you set a
10-minute timer and write about anything
that comes to mind at the end of the
timer you zoom out read over what you've
written and you write a one- sentence
summary for any ideas that stand out to
you but if you want to begin working
with ideas then jot down any thought
that intrigues you you want to write
about and set a timer for 10 or 15
minutes and let your mind wander while
you keep that idea in view so you're
still working with words you're writing
down anything that comes to mind but
you're trying to stay oriented toward
that single idea at the end you repeat
this process you look at your words to
find any ideas that stand out you
summarize those ideas at the bottom and
then you can alternate again between
working with words and working with
ideas this interaction between working
with words and working with ideas is
exactly what I use anytime I feel stuck
writing and it'll stop you sitting back
and worrying about what to write about
because you know exactly what to do over
time your body of work starts to build
up and take on a life of its own but
eventually we need to start preparing
these ideas into something that readers
can find valuable now if you check with
most of the writing advice out there
you're going to get tips on formal
elements of writing like grammar and
organization but the problem is that
readers don't give a toss about grammar
and organization so in order to learn
how to develop your ideas into valuable
writing watch this video next because
it's going to show you how to position
your ideas as the solution to problems
that readers actually care about so be
sure to go check it out
[Music]